Columbus has like Columbus is like the Beatles of exploring, right?
Like they're just the ones, you know, if you're like, what was the,
what's the biggest rock band of all time? You'd be like, Oh, the Beatles.
That's just what Columbus is. Like people, they teach them to everybody.
So everyone's like, Oh, it's club.
Like I literally thought Columbus sailed here, saw it,
went back and was like, Oh, this is the whole land. And everyone's like, cool,
cool. Yeah. The way they teach you in school, there's,
there's never any violence. There's never any phone torture or rape or slavery.
That is kind of like, so Columbus sailed here with three ships, the painter.
They mean on the Santa. I know all of them. And they're like, then, you know,
like I had an aunt Nina, Marie, I was like,
yay. You get 1492. They're like, that's it. You get an a in history. Yeah.
And then like, and then as you start to go on, like as like, you know,
time goes on, you're like, Oh wait, there was some evil that up there, like,
you know, I remember I like took a class in, uh,
like a college professor just casually through it. And it's like, yeah,
Columbus is one of the first people to experiment with biological warfare.
And I was like, huh. It was like, Hey,
gave blankets filled with smallpox and native Americans. I was like, Oh, what?
Sister? Mary never told us that the ocean blue in 1492,
I'm like, wait. So he killed every I'll be like, but they got vaccines. Right.
He's like, no, they killed half the population.
But that's what we got to do for our country. I was like, Oh.
For me, it's falling asleep at 33 to an episode of ancient aliens,
smoking a joint and then waking up. And they were like,
Columbus raped most of the women. And you're like, what's up?
What's going on? Cause you realize that he, yeah,
he basically brought the Spaniards.
To be like, yo, grab some people.
Because that was like big business back then. And then, um, you know,
but it's interesting because like in certain neighborhoods, like here,
we're in Bay Ridge, Brooklyn, and this is like pretty conservative neighborhood.
I remember I have a friend, my big, big Ryan he's a cop lives in Bay Ridge.
And I remember like a couple of years ago when they were changing.
Well I guess they have now legally changed it to indigenous people's day. Right?
It's like, it's not called Columbus day or it still is.
They celebrate both.
They sell it. But,
but in like another city it's just indigenous peoples or it's just Columbus.
Certain States and certain cities just recognize it as Columbus day
and other cities and States recognize it as both.
And some people just do indigenous people.
God, that's so funny. It's like sexuality in this country or there's,
there's still the, you know,
like cities that are like man or woman sanctity of marriage.
And then there's some people that are like, listen, if you're BI,
that's just what you are. If you want to be in Columbus,
if you want to be indigenous. And there's other people that are like, honey,
we're coming hot gay sex right here. It's indigenous people's day.
Like what it is, because there's,
what's the thing about Americans that, uh,
ultimately is a weakness for us is we latch onto narratives
in anyone that tries to change that narrative or immediately like you're
attacking everything I love. Right. Where it's like, nah, not really.
We're just trying to clarify some certain specific things. Yeah.
Yeah. I think like the problem is with like looking back in history,
like things with Columbus is like,
you're gonna find everybody was and in today's standards, uh,
pizza back then everybody was doing what he was doing.
The dudes were wearing these hot wigs. Yeah.
Just salient selling people into slavery. It just raping and pillows.
Yeah. Cause a man look at how quick the world changes. And like,
I remember like the movie waiting just came out on Netflix and I've seen waiting
a bunch of times, but it just came out on Netflix, you know, with, uh, with, uh.
Brian ran all Justin Long. Yeah. It's a great guy.
But then the whole premise of the movie is if you get stuck,
if you get caught with, uh, looking at another employee's Dick,
they play a game looking at another guy's Dick. They kick you in the for being,
and it's like, that was a number one comedy movie just 10, 15 years ago.
And now if you came to that premise,
you'd get canceled just for trying to pitch.
Dude, have you tried doing that at an Applebee's now? Like you're out,
you're out, dude. We can't have you at the beach.
So imagine in 1492, hundreds of years ago, the things that they were doing,
which were, they didn't realize that they were doing harm. I mean,
they probably did, but it was just like business was business back then.
And that's what it is. So it's like,
if you want to go back and cancel everybody, it's like, guess what?
It wasn't just old white explorers that were doing bad. Everybody,
every human being was living a different life with the way like America is,
you know, now like even white people it's w it's interesting Yonis.
And I honest read the article and then he told me about it.
It was fascinating that actually like, you know, like we're all created equal.
It's like, there's scientific proof.
Now they believe that that's actually not true.
Like we both liked Europeans and people more Northern from
more Northern countries come from a different strand of chimpanzee
DNA, then people more South. So it was like two slightly different,
but slightly different, but actual different types of human beings.
That's what they think. This is all pre you know, early signs.
But the Northern European DNA,
the one like that mostly white people are from is like 10 times more
vicious Chimp than the Southern ones.
So that's why it's like a European settler coming in and being vicious.
This article was saying their scientific evidence had potentially very early
stages backs all that up where it's like white people are just more evil
because of their DNA. That's what they said.
White people are the pit bull of humans where it's just like,
if there's an, if there's an unmanned white person that walks in, you go,
what is he going to do? What's he going to do? Can you really trust him?
If I ever had to get a snap? I don't know.
I don't know that a Rottweiler walks over, like, he's the problem?
Cause he's black.
He thinks we're like, America's not innocent. You know that doesn't make me say,
I want to hate America. No, it's just good to learn. But these things,
like there are these over correctness where it's like,
really now we're going to find about indigenous people's day.
It's like just shut it. Just kind of admit that there's blood on our hands.
And that, that helps the whole situation.
So like when you see a good marriage,
like a really good marriage and they had this honesty where they're like, yeah,
she was a slept for like 10 years and now we're great. And we're like,
not gonna get me going. She's like, what do you want me to do? I this brother.
And it was 10 years or whatever. And you're like, I love her. God, I love her.
But they, they just acknowledge a shared history where.
And that's what it is.
It's like calling indigenous people's day or Columbus day.
That shouldn't be a fight like that. Shouldn't be like,
I'm taking a stand on one or the other it's stupid. It's entitlement.
And makes us feel like it made this, I don't know this year,
if you'll have such a stink about what it's going to be called.
Cause now we're in a pandemic. So it's like,
now it's like the same thing it's like now nobody cares.
We were saying this last podcast, like nobody cares about the straws anymore.
Nobody cares if there's plastic being used on the ventilator that could
strangle.
But this is that's, that's kind of this,
the exact prime example of what all this is. It's like,
I bet native Americans don't really give a about the indigenous people's
day. As much as they Ida, I'm not speaking for them. But I'm saying like,
look at the Dakota pipeline. You look at dude, look at Sturgis. This year,
Sturgis happens in the black Hills of South Dakota, which is Lakota nation.
That is still there. That's like their most sacred land and Sturgis is apart.
And they had like 300,000 people without masks during COVID just being like
whatever. And it was the protests of the natives that were there that were like,
dude, this. Why are you guys coming in?
And just bringing this is you're doing it. Yeah.
Doing the thing again where you're bringing a disease in,
when we're telling you, we don't want you here. Hold on. I gotta,
she smash mouth
without a of lib tarred cloth.
I'm I might as well be wearing somebody far skin on my face.
You just want to see history, repeat itself, go read up about,
about the Sioux nation,
protesting Sturgis rally this year, the bike rally,
because it's just a bunch of fat people with hepatitis being like run up on my
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. I don't believe in that. And you're like,
Hey, you guys suck. You're the problem. Yeah.
It's not like you're doing the lead. I don't know, man.
I just had that bug me like reading that. Cause you're like, man,
you guys are just doing the same thing, same thing.
But you're just acting like what? It's my rights.
I go to Sturgis every year and I watch my wife,
my fat wife get gang-banged by the hell's angels. And then I go home.
I go home and I listen to Legion and skank were shout out Legion [inaudible].
Um, but see the, the whole reason why? Cause a lot of people like, Oh,
we've never even met a native American. Why do we care? That's on purpose.
The United States government in the 19th century adopted a policy to isolate and
native Americans in places with few natural resources far from con far from
contact with the developing us economy because they knew that their land that
they were living on had all the and they were like,
let's just move them over here. And we'll, you know,
are new home near forget about their, their old home.
And they'll like their new home.
And now they just all live on for the most part reservations. Um,
making Arizona ice tea. That's what.
It is. I've thought about. This one makes you.
Does anything make you? As much as when you drink a can of 99 cents Arizona.
Honestly, I'm too adapted to it. It's just fine. I can,
I it's been awhile until I found out how much sugar was actually there.
But I used to rip those green teas.
Used to drink the raspberry iced teas and then just let it rip. I mean.
Oh, it was crazy. Yeah. I thought the green teas were healthy.
I genuinely thought the Arizona green teas for four years of my life,
I scientifically were like, yeah, this is like a healthy green tea. I'm like,
I get in cam a meal and zinc and stuff.
You have Arizona. I seen him or do they make it? Or I can look for it anymore,
I guess,
because like once you grow up and you realize how much sugar is in like your
mind, I was like, don't ever go near that mountain deal. I'm like,
did they stop making mountain Dew? It's like, no, your brain just let,
just says you can have that. So it's out.
Yeah. You're a kid. You're like, yeah, no, but they got,
they got new flavors now, dude. Oh yeah, they got, we got Baja blast.
You got, you can get into it dude, but multiple flavors. But.
Thank you so much for watching. Hope you enjoyed the last video.
Don't forget to tell your friends like subscribe and turn on notifications.
[Inaudible].